la cinemateca evacuada se está
presentando esta semana una
retrospectiva de la carrera del cineasta
mexicano carlos reygadas que está de
visita aquí en quebec con la directora y
actriz natalia lópez están aquí en
nuestros estudios acompañándonos en
radio canadá internacional cómo les va
muy bien gracias muy contentos de estar
aquí muy bien muchas gracias qué bueno
que están acá carlos usted en sus
historias en las películas que nos ha
presentado a través de los años desde
los años noventas y hasta ahora siempre
nos ha contado historias que
que son muy variadas que son muy
diversas que cuentan la historia de
ricos de pobres de gente del campo gente
de la ciudad de todo tipo de historias
hay algún diría usted hilo conductor
porque yo veo la retrospectiva lo veo
las cinco películas que estaban
presentando a la cinémathèque québécoise
y me parecen que representan a usted
pero usted ve un hilo conductor en todo
lo que ha hecho hasta ahora
la contradicción humana seguramente
la que se choca que se da entre lo que
entre lo que deseamos y lo que podemos
hacer por un lado y también por otro
lado entre los deseos en sí mismos que
son contradictorios casi siempre a nivel
personal y luego el contacto que se da
con otros donde ya hay un doble nivel de
contradicción puesto que se cuentan las
contracciones individuales más las de
los demás y la voluntad de armonizar
siempre y de siempre fallar y siempre
caer y siempre volverse a levantar en
esta lucha por la contracción yo creo
que además estamos en una época que la
relación con el otro es algo que puede
en ocasiones resultar conflictivos sobre
todo en méxico también pero en una
sociedad como la canadiense por ejemplo
vemos la relación al otro que es muy am
está en este momento como muy observada
en la mira de todos los medios de
comunicación hay tantos inmigrantes
llegando es una sociedad ya hecha por
inmigrantes pero al mismo tiempo
seguimos siendo todos el otro de lo del
otro fuimos siempre el otro del otro
entonces me parece que que por ese lado
lo entiendo que es un poco
es poner en frente a diferentes entes
que a lo mejor no se hubieran puesto
enfrente puede ser yo diría que lo que
se hable es algo humano pero
evidentemente en sociedades como esta se
suma un valor más o un efecto más que es
la el intento de las obras de la
regulación casi absurdo en muchos casos
de la conducta humana las reglas
y esa búsqueda de la red de las reglas
muchas veces lleva a lugares de alto
estrés de mayor tensión humana
e irónicamente de menor comunicación y
de mucha intolerancia también entonces
si efectivamente todo se pretende
regular desde lo que podemos decir lo
que podemos pensar cómo tenemos que
comportarnos en todo momento y se llega
a situaciones un poco paroxísticas de
llamamos le de neurosis donde el nivel
de tolerancia frente al prójimo se
vuelve muy bajo efectivamente es uno de
los grandes problemas de los países
desarrollados a través de las reglas y
el orden que sirven para mucho pero que
crean mucho mucho estrés a nivel de las
relaciones humanas usted cómo ve está
está esta particularidad usted también
es directora de cine es actriz y además
es editora no sé si el editor es la de
término adecuado en español editora mont
como se diría se puede decir montajista
aumentar ahora está creo que ahora la
montadora creo que editor es más
pero también se usa si también se usa
soy más editora que otra cosa realmente
es la primera película en la que actuó
no soy actriz entrenada ni tampoco
directora este estudié para director en
la escuela y según un par de cortos
ahora estoy preparando una película como
directora pero todos juntos así es en
proyección en proyección en movimiento
justamente usted es la una de las
protagonistas de esta nueva película que
está presentando carlos reygadas nuestro
tiempo de donde en donde él también
actúa y justo en esa en esa película en
lo que he podido ver de la película
porque está en premiar a quien en
montreal en esta semana justamente lo
que he podido ver es que también hay ahí
esa hay mucho amor
hay mucha hay mucho justamente en
entender al otro independientemente de
que no seamos diferentes culturalmente
como vivió que que retiene usted esta
experiencia como actriz por primera vez
pero en general como como artista
y creo que
y actuar te pone en un lugar de hiper
contacto con lo que te rodea con los
otros seres humanos con las cosas con el
medio ambiente y con todo lo que está
alrededor y creo que eso es de una
riqueza inmensa y te hace de alguna
manera sentir todo el tiempo magnificada
mente este los sentimientos del otro y
las palabras y el tacto los sentidos etc
creo que esa es la experiencia que más
más me llevo de alguna manera al
exacerbación de
de la realidad que me que percibía en
ese momento en alguna de las entrevistas
que escuché o que leí de usted carlos
usted dice en algún momento una de las
cosas que son uno de los problemas de
las tristezas digamos de las sociedades
contemporáneas es que estamos tratando
de imitar la realidad en el cine
entonces voy a tratar de saber dice hay
cinco años de sad problems with
contemporary cinema store in store y
dominique reality entonces si uno de los
problemas del cine contemporáneo es que
estamos tratando de contar historias que
cuente imitan la realidad a usted le
gusta contar la realidad u otra cosa
no al contrario yo creo que para poder
el cine no es una realidad
ningún arte lo es por lo tanto necesita
haber una suerte de transfiguración
y ese efecto debe ocurrir en un escritor
debe ocurrir en un cineasta cada uno con
un diferente método para que lo que se
percibe tenga un impacto igual de
profundo o mayor quizás que la realidad
si uno imita la realidad que es como yo
creo que hace muchas películas
no ocurre es ese fenómeno de
transposición y además la realidad como
no se puede imitar perfectamente sólo se
imita y en un código en un código de
actuación que ya conocemos que es el
código de la actuación de la mente de
las series o del de hollywood que es muy
parecido que es el del cine mundial que
tiene un ritmo específico y una forma de
hacerse que no no es nunca está cercano
a lo individual a lo personal es un
método digamos se hace con un libro de
instrucciones y esa metodología que
pretende imitar la realidad ya la
codificar la tenemos así codificada y
así la percibimos pero no en realidad y
entonces hay una especie de desperdicio
oportunidad para poder hacer algo que
entre en otro lugar de la visión y de la
percepción personal en el espectador
eso es eso es un poco lo que he dicho no
es que el cine es irónico pero en lugar
de hacer el cine son imágenes y se
desperdicia cuando se hacen imágenes con
él el cine poderoso curiosamente hace
conceptos y contrariamente a la
literatura que es un lenguaje de la
representación
la literatura normalmente hace imágenes
poderosas cuando es justamente un
lenguaje del canal de imaginario
entonces eso es parte de lo que trata de
ser es algo bastante claro y complejo
para decir aquí hago casa que sólo lo
anuncios y superficialmente
sin embargo en la nueva película nuestro
tiempo cuenta una cuenta un tipo de
realidad no sé si son universos
paralelos son cosas que suceden que le
pueden suceder a mucha gente de alguna
manera la universalidad del tema
no nos lleva a sentirnos oa
identificarnos con los personajes que
vemos en el cine un poco es lo que lo
que logran hacerlas lo que logra sea el
cine también y usted natalie está
presentando está preparando como dice
proyectos en cine también como director
haya visto digamos los diferentes
aspectos de contar una historia porque
cree usted que usted como artista quiere
necesita contar historias porque porque
es importante contar sus historias
si yo justo comparto con con carlos
que el cine no es la potencialidad
máxima del arte cinematográfico no es
contar historias
sino probablemente expresar una visión
sobre la existencia
y sobre los humanos
entonces creo que de ahí ahí está mi
necesidad este también de compartir y de
expresar eso que que veo y que siento de
la existencia y de la vida
carlos es definitivamente un gran
maestro y su cine lo es en todo sentido
este es un cine que se puede analizar
con todos los detalles y que es
expresión de esto
no es quiere decir que si efectivamente
le cogió con natalia pero claro que se
cuenta una historia en una película
curiosamente la mayoría la gente habla
de la historia contada porque es lo que
es más fácil de percibir lo más fácil de
identificar y si es así
pero creo que lo que la tele dice es que
el objetivo fundamental del cine no es
contar una historia como nos lo enseñan
en muchas escuelas de cine porque
entonces pues cada vez vamos a tratar de
estar buscando historias nuevas per se
como si ese fue el objetivo siendo que
la literatura es mucho más propicia para
contar historias en realidad tal vez es
más fácil verlas en la tele uno aburrido
historias pero es muy la literatura es
mucho más adecuada
en cambio el cine se acerca a eso que
dijo natalia que es una especie de
acercamiento a la existencia
en todo caso la experiencia de la
excepción de existencia de alguna
persona entonces en ese sentido hay un
poder muy fuerte el cine y tienen lo
interesante es ver cómo ve a alguien o
como cuenta alguien una historia más que
la historia en sí misma sino cada vez
hacemos historias más alocadas más
excéntricas con el ánimo de novedad en
lugar de darnos cuenta que simplemente
lo más interesante es la visión personal
y ustedes tienen trabajando juntos mucho
tiempo ya hacen han hecho varios
proyectos juntos han sido han sido
honrados en varios en varios festivales
por su trabajo juntos que es lo que como
evolucionado su relación entre el
trabajo como cómo ha crecido porque
ustedes comenzaron hace tiempo y han ido
creciendo juntos pero como la describir
cómo describiría en esta evolución que
han ido viviendo juntos
natalia creo que
creo que la evolución está en más bien
la división del trabajo no crees creo
que cada vez hemos compartido más pero
al mismo tiempo he hecho menos juntos
este
creo que editamos dos películas juntos y
tenemos unos estudios de postproducción
juntos tenemos hijos vivimos en el campo
y compartimos mucho la vida que está muy
relacionada con el trabajo también pero
creo que hemos sabido a lo largo del
tiempo dividir mucho es mucho el trabajo
de la
para potenciar digamos un poco el
talento de cada uno me imagino o no
por sanidad este emocional y psicológica
creo que además es muy bonito poder
compartir y llegar a tu pareja poder
compartir algo que solo tú viviste o que
está que no está rondando entre los dos
todo el día
[Risas]
tenemos mucho mucho contacto juntos por
lo tanto en los aspectos profesionales
profesionales tratamos de tener más
distancia precisamente porque nos
conocimos a través de un aspecto
profesional que ella vino a editar en
película luz silenciosa a chihuahua
cuando estábamos allá
y bueno son el 2006 y desde entonces
hemos estado juntos entonces como no
podemos separar la parte de la
convivencia y los hijos de hoy no
podemos y no queremos además pues por lo
menos donde si podemos es un poco en el
trabajo entonces tratamos el natale que
hacer su película la va a ser pronto yo
lo mío y tenemos buenos diálogos y
digamos que para mí la opinión de
natalia siempre es importantísima en
temas de edición y en temas de fondo en
cualquier aspecto de lo que yo hago
pero somos más como una pareja que puede
charlar de cosas que nos gustan y que
nos atraen a veces estamos en desacuerdo
pero el punto es que podemos tener un
buen espejo pero no quiere decir que
necesariamente el trabajo el trabajo lo
que vamos a hacer juntos sobre todo el
trabajo de ella como directora ella lo
está siendo sola y yo también en esta
última película puede ser que está en
ella la ley de solá por primera vez
irónicamente y solo quiero decir
[Música]
qué les produce estar aquí para este
evento porque están prepara este para
esta retrospectiva a la cinemateca tiene
mucho prestigio aquí en canadá en todo
canadá no sólo en que ve que es una es
una institución muy importante que les
produce estar acá presentando esta nueva
esta nueva película cómo se sienten
muy contentos la verdad venimos con
nuestros hijos además que estaban muy
muy emocionados por ver la nieve
entonces viajamos todos con mucha
emoción y mucha ilusión de llegar al
invierno del norte este seguimos muy
emocionados y la verdad es que compartir
la película con el público siempre es
muy reconfortante creo que es el
realmente es el momento en el que
sientes que has concluido como que se
cierra un iniciará el ciclo y por otro
lado también la cinemateca me parece que
tiene 57 años por allí fue fundado el 62
que tengo entendido
no es tan lindo las cuentas por ahí y
más de medio siglo es un clásico de las
cinematecas del mundo entonces estamos
muy muy agradecidos de que haya interés
por las películas
amate escalante también estuvo
introspectiva es cierto recientemente
exacto y bueno en el público de montreal
él siempre tenía una tradición muy
fuerte de amor al cine del cine de autor
que también bueno corte en canadá en
general el final de toronto tú lo sabes
muy fuerte es más cíclico quizás pero
acá hay una tradición muy fuerte de
cinefilia y bueno yo personalmente
considero tanto el director de cine como
como aficionado al cine por lo tanto la
cineteca las retrospectivas y los
trabajos bien enfocados en autores
cuando puedes ver la totalidad de la
obra de un autor siempre tomas otra
perspectiva en la percepción de lo que
la autoricé de lo que su obra es y eso
es siempre ese es algo que solidifica
la percepción de un creador digamos un
director de cine y es algo que se
agradece
carlos reygadas natalia lópez muchísimas
gracias por pasar por nuestros estudios
gracias a que la paz entiendo y que los
40 centímetros de nieve les caigan bien